[Musique]
mais schneider je pense que c'est un
secret pour personne mais beaucoup
changé ça ne doit pas tu as et répond
plus est ce que vous aimez mieux comme
ça oui j'aime bien pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez changé parce qu on n y est pas
ce que vous étiez avant il y a rien qui
me fait plus de peur que l'enduit et
puis je ne l'avais pas connu ça avant il
ya deux ans et demi que je sentis c'est
la première fois je n'avais pas connu
avant parce que j'étais très bien
c'était très bien comme si si comme
princesse non seulement dans le film sur
l'écran on m'a fait ça même dans la vie
publique en allemagne en autriche c'est
très bien personne qui n'aimeraient pas
ça mais il ya deux ans et demi après
avoir tourné présent inconnu alain après
avoir tourné trois films dans le même
genre en france
c'était fini est ce que vous allez me
dire comment est ce que vous rappelez
exactement les circonstances dans
lesquelles vous êtes vite le dit oui je
sais je me rappelle très bien c'était au
moment où la nature les amis leurs
locaux j'étais avec lui je le suivis et
puis j'ai connu des gens comme j'ai
connu visconti j'ai connu clément j'ai
connu des gens que j'aime
jamais vu j'ai entendu parler c'était un
rêve de les connaître de travailler avec
eux je savais très bien personne ne
s'intéresse à moi pour de bonnes raisons
j'étais là à ne rien faire vrai dallas
est bien dur lui un homme près de moi
qui m'aidait qui me qui essayait de
donner confiance mais ça n'allait pas
très bien rester parce que c'est à dire
quand on parle de 6,6 en france dans le
fond on ne sait pas très bien ce que
c'est si c'était un premier typiquement
germanique
c'était fait pour l'allemagne l'autriche
et yann nouard oui c'est ça mais c'était
une très jolie pâtisserie d'ailleurs la
petite fille vit noisette une chose
extrêmement agréable très bonne mais
hier il y en a par exemple s'en priver
mais ce qu'on ne sait pas très bien en
france et que vous étiez a tellement
identifié au personnel de 6,6 que ont
donné vous en vouloir de changer sisi
qu'est ce que c'était c'était
sainte-thérèse de lisieux qui veut des
cinémas quoi c'était quelque chose dans
le genre là et il fallait surtout pas
que la sainte mort
quel poids l'appétit terrestre et vous
étiez vraiment très prisonniers avaient
cela oui vous savez bien souvent là que
vous aviez avoir combattu et les causes
c'était comme vous savez je me sentais
comme dans une veste qui est devenu un
peu trop petit ça craque et c'est
presqu'un de la gratitude de vouloir
changer
oui vous tourniez le dos à un public
quand même qu'ils voudraient fait ce que
vous étiez tous les mieux ou pas oui ça
fait peur aussi
oui vous ne vous disiez pas je vais
mettre tout le monde à dos si bien sûr
je le savais est-ce qu'il vaut pas mieux
que je continue tranquillement à faire
ce que le cul bien sûr je me posais des
questions jour et nuit
j'avais bien des gens comme en famille
etc et les amis de là bas près de moi
qui me disait tu es folle on ne peut pas
se faire saturer fusent l'argent tu
tournes quand vous dites le dos un
public énorme qui est très gentil thèmes
comme ça pourquoi changer et puis qui
sait si tu peux faire autre chose
il ya une autre chose aussi c'est que
finalement les acteurs qui ont réussi
qui sont identifiés à ce rôle n'ont
jamais pu s'en débarrasser
il est évident si vous voulez vous
pouvez aller chez chanel et changer
votre façon de vous habiller
mais c'est fernandel pour estimer les
dents mais il est très difficile tout
d'un coup de tourner le dos à sa légion
mais ça on allait voir un faible aux
gardes parce qu'ils se touchent et
l'oreille les six dans un film et
c'était pas de chillwave a dit que le
film était mauvais marquer le fait
qu'ils se touchent doit il supposait que
tout le reste était était bon et est ce
que tu appelles public
alors comment est ce que vous avez fait
pour détruire cette légende car vous
êtes la première déjà c'était un
personnage vous croyez je pense tout bas
si j'y suis toujours là qui vous tire
par l'espace de l'authority tailleur
chômage voulez vous avez un plan non
vous aider je m'arrête de tourner tant
qu'on ne propose pas quelque chose
auquel sa wish we aujourd'hui romy
schneider à cause de votre courage à
cause de votre intelligence aussi
toutefois cet incident il n'ya pas un
grand metteur en scène qui n'ait envie
de travailler avec vous c'est une chose
qui fit un matinée sculley trois ans
luchino visconti a fait appel à vous et
pas seulement à cause de vos relations
parce qu'il savait ces gens ne gaspille
pas leur talent avec les outils peuvent
être poli pour être bien élevé mais
jamais dans le métier non papa il faut
pas les choses pour rien tout à l'heure
vous avez quitté cannes
vous allez repartir pour paris et à
monsieur qui vous attend ces personnes
wells qui doit signer travaille pas avec
la première venue au fait le procès avec
lui oui donc ça ça va plutôt faire
plaisir beaucoup mais les deux ans et
demi dynaction volontaire avec elle vous
allez passer à quel état d'esprit vous
trouviez vous
ah j'étais bien perdu
j comme je vous ai dit je t'ai près de
quelqu'un qui travaille j'ai connu des
gens avec qui j'avais envie envie de
travailler qui s'intéressaient pas à moi
j'ai vu des journaux qui ont écrit parlé
d'une façon de moi que je n'aimais plus
je veux pas envie qu'on parle comme ça
de moi je sentis l'autre chose je senti
que je voulais que je peux faire autre
chose
c'est à dire que on parlait toujours de
vous c'était peut-être ça qui était
grave on n'aurait pas parlé sanyo va lui
oui presse car vous étiez toujours un
sujet d'article vous n'étiez plus un
motif de films non ça qui compte et non
ce qui est intéressant pour les
journalistes en ce qui me concerne c'est
qu'elle est devenue
justement cette jeune actrice qui est
plein d pas si brillant et avec la
fausse note apitoyer à la fin c'est vrai
j'aurais presque préféré ce que le
téléphone sonne plus pour ce pour
justement c'est pour qu'ils sont laids
pour ce personnage là qui n'existait
plus il est évidemment très difficile de
dire aux gens que vous voyez toute la
journée qui était déjà qu'il avait envie
de travailler
est-ce qu'on n'est pas quelque chose
pour moi évidemment une chose que vous
pouviez pas faire
oui vous étiez trop connu hélas pour
pouvoir demander quoi que ce soit je
n'aurais pas pu oui mais est-ce que vous
êtes seul avec qui je parlais c'était
luchino c'est vrai le kilo avoue m'a
écouté c'était le premier qui m'écoutez
où j'avais l'impression qu'ils s'en
fichent pas ce que je dis qu'il
s'intéresse un puce malgré qu en ce qu
on ne se presse pas il m'a compris je
lui disais il parce qu'il était avant
tout
pour moi un ami je lui ai expliqué ce
que je voulais faire et comment je me
sens en ce moment là mais il m'a rien
demandé il n'a pas dit qu'il a une idée
où il avait déjà pour la pièce dommage
parce qu'il ya des gens qui me fait des
vrais conseils des conseils par exemple
il faut s'habiller autrement il faut
lire tel livre vous faire telle chose
la façon dont vous êtes à ubs n'ont pas
non vous même
non pas qu'on m'a donné des conseils
will pas des gens non g20 seul ce
dernier
oui qu'est ce qu'ils disent est là mais
c'était pas pour les choses extérieures
habillé ou sommes aussi ici aussi quand
on parlait de ça mais c'était trop beau
trop à répéter des choses extérieures
avant tout c'était mon état il ya là me
disais à temps il vous disait que toi
quand vous étiez décourager j'étais
furieuse non mais lui que ce qui est des
oui oui vous prenez par l'épaule et oui
et ça va s'arranger où il veut vous une
vraie conversation
non non il m'a dit il était merveilleux
il m'a dit bien sûr ma 10e attends
attends itunes est inapte à 80 ans tu
attends attends
c'était très facile à lui j'y vais te
fasse effet c'est facile à dire mais je
ne vais je n'avais pas attendu plus
attendre combien temps gérer attendre
pour faire quelque chose du bien à pour
faire quelque chose
ce que j'ai envie de faire et il m'a pas
laissé me avec raison je ne l'est pas
toujours compris et je crois 108-100
quelqu'un que ce que c'était lui pour
moi derrière moi près de moi qui m'a dit
non non non et puis là tu ne le font pas
et ça tu fais pas et je ne sais pas si
j'aurai résiste peut-être peut-être
j'aurais fait une part dont une connerie
et son lit ne croyez pas qu'on peut être
sale dans la vie coteaux faire quelque
chose d'important
non on a besoin les autres oui est ce
que tu sais moi nous parlons nous
parlons d'alain delon je vois d'ailleurs
dépasser le problème
il est très difficile pour deux acteurs
de poursuivre une vie parallèle être
deux dans la vie quand on est acteur
c'est déjà difficile serait ce parce que
cet acte est d'accord plus plus
compliqué parce que finalement on est
toujours un peu en concurrence les mains
qui se lèvent que l'autre oui mais la
course de misano ça alors ça je ne
connais pas cette façon des jalousies si
vous voulez pas du tout ni lui ni moi
mais j'avoue que c'est pour moi la chose
la plus difficile de vraiment de réussir
en plus de gens jeunes comme ou deux de
faire une vie ensemble lui une vraie vie
après à côté de ce métier plus
importante le métier oui pour moi et
c'était pas vrai j'étais bien près prête
à livrer corps et âme comme on dit chez
nous à ce métier mais ça ça ça me fait
bien peur un moment parce que si c'est
bien un moment où ça peut s'arrêter et
surtout pour une femme
un jour on est plus jeune plus joli et
puis si ça s'arrête on n'a plus rien si
on a pas quelqu'un ou une vie où un coin
où on peut aller loin d'un enfant non
pour moi c'est j'ai quelque chose au
dessus de ce métier je m'accroche et je
sais je veux garder
[Musique]